We now have as of this recording, 71% of precincts
reporting in Monday nights, Iowa caucus.
I will talk later about how Iowa should not
be the first in the nation primary.
More on that later or tomorrow.
The results didn't come into us on Monday
night because of the total crash of the technology
used to report results in Iowa and we had
a very embarrassing 24 hours for the Iowa
democratic party and for the democratic national
committee and a 62% of results were released
Tuesday afternoon.
As of this recording, we've gotten another
nine percentage points of the results.
71% have been released.
Most analysts believe that Pete boot edge
edge who is now leading will be the eventual
winner of the Iowa caucus.
Now remember, these are proportional delicate
allocations, so it will be a mathematically
meaningless victory for boot edge edge relative
to Bernie Sanders in the grand scheme of things.
But we'll come back to that.
Looking at the results as of a few minutes
ago, Pete boot edge edge with just under 27%
of the delegates, Bernie Sanders with just
over 25% of the delegates, despite as you
might notice, Bernie having more votes in
the popular vote.
As of this counting, you'll notice Elizabeth
Warren in third place with about 18% Joe Biden
in fourth place with 15% and uh, Biden followed
very closely by Senator Amy Klobuchar with
about 12 and a half percent of the vote.
The only other people getting any delegates
are Andrew Yang with 1% and Tom Stier with
0.3% everybody else, including Michael Bloomberg
and tools see Gabard with literal goose eggs.
Just zeros.
Now without going into the detail, the reason
that Pete can have more delegates, while Bernie
has more raw votes, it's similar to how you
can win the electoral college, but lose the
popular vote the way Donald Trump did in 2016
the delegates are apportioned at a local level
and you can win some precincts with a big
popular vote margin, but then lose a lot of
little priests or a lot of, lose a lot of
other precincts by small margins and end up
with a popular vote win and without the most
elegance.
We don't yet have the final numbers in the
end.
More than likely, this will mean 10 pledged
delegates for Pete and 10 pledge delegates
for Bernie.
They might end up deferring by one or two.
That's as of right now, we are still waiting
on that last 29% of the vote.
This does not put anybody in any kind of a
decisive position.
We will very quickly get another democratic
debate this Friday.
We will then go right to the New Hampshire
primary on Tuesday, which will be 24 more
delegates in total.
Bernie right now very much in the lead in
New Hampshire.
So remember this is one of four primaries
before March 3rd super Tuesday.
The delegates are apportioned proportionately,
um, and the DNC is increasingly panicking
about, uh, Joe Biden's poor performance and
Bernie's good performance.
We'll talk a little bit later about the idea
that's being floated about giving super delegates
the power they had in 2016 which had been
taken away from them in New Hampshire.
A Bernie Sanders.
Remember Bernie won handily in the 2016 New
Hampshire primary.
He had about 60% of the vote to Hillary Clinton's
38%.
Massive victory in New Hampshire in 2016 but
again, it's 24 delegates.
Iowa was 41.
New Hampshire is only 24.
The big repercussion here is not for Buddha
judge or for Bernie.
The big repercussions here are for Joe Biden.
Joe Biden's terrible performance has shaken
the establishment to its core and later in
the show we're going to dig into that in more
detail.
Elizabeth Warren's poor performance also leading
to some deep thinking about her future.
She got just four pledged delegates and is
currently pulling in fourth place in New Hampshire.
Very unlikely New Hampshire will give Warren
any momentum.
There was a report yesterday, I don't know
if it's been confirmed that she has been canceling
and rescheduling a lot of, uh, plans travel
to both Nevada and South Carolina, the third
and fourth primary States.
It does not seem like things are going well
for Warren and really they haven't been for
about, I think about six or seven weeks at
this point that we've been covering.
So those are the numbers as of right now in
the Iowa caucus results by the time you watch
this clip, by the time we publish today's
show, we may have 100% of the results or closer
to it, but generally speaking, these are the
results.
A, uh, overperformance by Pete boot edge edge,
significant under-performance by Joe Biden
and Bernie Sanders, roughly percentage wise
with the level of support that the polls indicated
going in.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram for more on this and other
stories act.
David Pakman